هيا نَمْ يَا عُصْفُورْ
هيا  نَمْ يَا أَمُّورْ
أَغْمِضْ عَيْنَيْكَ الحُلْوِينْ
اللَّيلُ هُدُوءٌ وَسُكُونْ
هيا نَمْ يَا هُمَامْ
حَلِّقْ بِسَمَاءِ الأَحْلاَمْ
هُوو هُووو يَا شَطُّورْ
اصْعَدْ أَجْنِحَةَ الحَمَامْ
يَا عُصْفُورَ البَسَاتِينْ
حَلَّ الَّليلُ لِلحُلْوِينْ
فِى عُشِّكَ هَيَّا وَارْتَاحْ
أَغْمِضْ لِلحُلمِ العُيُونْ
هُووهُوو يَا حَمَامْ
نَامَ الحُلْوُ النَّاعِسُ نَامْ
اذهب اذهب لِلأَحْبَابْ
أَبْلِغْهُمْ مِنْهُ سَلاَمْ
يَا قَمَرَايَهْ يَا جَمِيلَةْ
هَدِّىْ أَنْوَارَكِ لَيْلَةْ
حَبيبى بِسَرِيرِهِ نَامْ
رُمُوشُه بِالنَّوم كَحِيلَةْ
هُووهُووو يَا نَجْمَاتْ
الْتَحِفِى بِظِلِّ الغَيْمَاتْ
قُولِى بِأُذُنِ العُصْفُورَةْ
كَيْ لاَ تَسْمَعْكِ النَّسَمَاتْ